welcome to Summer chores and uh hey you
okay uh-huh oh my God we're not even not
not that much time has elapsed and
um I'm worried about Sona most of all
you should be you should because she is
drinking a powerful rum drink Matt how
are you doing you said summer chores
instead of summer summer chores with
Kobe and the okay we're doing this
podcast don't you see
I don't think anyone said don't you see
since about
1944. don't you see we must win World
War II the best part is listeners you
can go to YouTube and check out all
kinds of clips from this series yeah if
you're if hearing about it doesn't annoy
you enough yeah and you want to see this
total meltdown of us outside on this
nice Veranda do you want to see the
three hottest people that you've ever
seen in your life so sexy I'm
wearing a bikini the size of a doily
yeah what are you doing with the cord
yeah I'm doing unibrow
you're doing crazy for the
people okay hey YouTube people hey
YouTube this is house sonar YouTube oh
you look fantastic you look amazing
thank you ah let me see you point it to
me whoa well I think the important thing
is that we're here we're together uh and
two of you are wasted I'd like to point
out that I'm a very thoughtful person
a very thoughtful person busted you
little Dandy yeah no I am not I blame
the microphone which is a Krieger which
is not the German brand I prefer it is
schluten dyden anyway I knew that it was
your birthday coming up and I tried very
hard to get you a wonderful this is for
you Mr Matt Gourley yes I tried to get
you the perfect gift I conspired I went
online and I found this place that would
sell me
mid-century vintage cocktail glasses
that looked like pineapples because they
have like a copper top they're really
cool looking and they have a built-in
straw and I thought oh my God this is so
matte girly and it's also so summer
s'mores I tried I ordered these things
and paid for them and now I would like
David hopping to enter the scene because
David I think you could maybe explain
David is my assistant who really does
things as opposed to Sona who pretends
to do things anyway
[Music]
so David does your day-to-day Assistant
duties and I do big picture
when I'm planning uh to launch
satellites my purchase of you know what
I have to say when I tried to outbid
Elon Musk for Twitter Sona was
instrumental
big picture but anyway uh do us a favor
yeah and tell us Mr hopping what's the
status because first of all take us
through it because we've talked about
this before but I ordered these glasses
and it was really excited for them to
come and then they weren't showing up
and then you told me there was a problem
and then you said an investigation has
been yeah it's kind of exciting oh a
little bit let's hear about it
um so they're not here that's pretty
exciting that's my favorite part of the
story they're missing
um I did check earlier and now it says
that a uh claim has been filed and it
now it says that I need to contact the
seller so basically we ordered these
from like not eBay but like in eBay it's
like I mean like in eBay so it's like
from a seller FB like I was like
messaging the girls room but it's called
Sapp dot com and
uh yeah it's not good Governor Brian
needs a friend is brought to you by
T-Mobile from listening to your favorite
podcast while driving cross country to
listening at home T-Mobile helps you
stay connected I wonder what people's
favorite podcast is oh I've got some
ideas actually it's one idea yeah you'll
figure it out T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can
have seamless video calling oh that's
good streaming your favorite podcast I'm
not gonna say which one it is yeah
downloading apps games boy you know what
a gamer I am you're such a gamer play
starbursters yeah or realm of Thanos
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at tmobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA the speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access detail t-mobile.com
she seems really nice though can I ask
you a question yeah my money has gone
through
yes yes so you're out of pocket at this
so I am out of pocket and and David just
be perfectly honest these weren't cheap
no okay so I am out of pocket this
amount of money and yet right now we're
just chairing these vague claims that
there's an investigation right like we
can see every step of the journey the
package went on like it went from
Connecticut to New Jersey to something
called Bell California that sounds nice
um that's been it was out for delivery
and then just vanished now what is that
in in your opinion David I know that
you're a very good detective what do you
think happened to the glasses if you had
to guess do you think someone stole them
along the way or do you think it's an
innocent accident I mean I don't want to
accuse anyone of stealing but I think
they were stolen let's be clear the real
tragedy is I've turned 50 years old and
I am weeks without gift yeah and I'll
tell you I don't know how much longer I
can hold on yeah well first of all it's
not just without gift you're weeks
without Twee cocktail glasses exactly
from the 1950s my reason for living yeah
exactly uh this is
um an injustice has been done good money
has been spent you know how hard I work
yeah and how uh much I deserve the money
that I make and you know that this is a
crime this is a terrible crime against a
great American who has brought laughter
to people for 30 years makes it about
himself when do we expect a resolution
yes thank you David oh you know what
Matt I apologize I did momentarily make
it about myself yeah and I'm sorry and I
just want you to know that Conan O'Brien
is sorry for the loss of the glasses
that Conan O'Brien when can we expect a
resolution for your services
two days ago and we there's no update
what investigation there's no
inspections
investigating the UPS is investigating
themselves so UPS oh this is ridiculous
you know what I'm sorry David I don't
want to throw you under the bus but I
would pretend that this happened if I
forgot to order something and then I
would have
I would pull them up but then everyone
would see how much you paid picture why
don't you get on this yeah oh yes
Sona Sona let me ask you a question how
would you I would call UPS and what
would you do I would give him a piece of
my mind let's role play that hi this is
UPS hi UPS this is Sona I'm calling from
uh you may have heard of him Conan
O'Brien never once heard of him okay
well we had a package okay and guess
what they never showed up this is your
literal job UPS to deliver this
you're right what's in the package it
doesn't matter what's in the package
you're right how can I locate it without
the contents you Dill what why do you
need content well you should be asking
me for my tracking number huh do you
even work for UPS no
you do I'm a champion
can I ask you a question yeah
your biggest insult is comparing someone
to a pickle yeah
wow what happened to you we I'll tell
you what we don't lose packages here at
UPS all right okay oh no no I would I
would get a I would call and get angry I
will say something okay David do it yeah
David can I David you do a great job
thank you but Sona is the OG and Sona
has a temper okay that is off the charts
it started nice but Sona I am saying a
positive thing which is I used to hear
Sona get on the phone half the time for
me to try and find out what had gone
wrong for me
no and she would get stuff done and then
half the time or maybe eighty percent of
the time it would be saying to someone
in L.A County
um I know I went too fast and gave me a
speeding ticket but you can't f with me
I'm good at getting out of speeding
speeding ticket like so yeah I have a
spotless record and I've gotten a lot of
tickets
so you're admitting that you did speed I
did and so I'm sorry when was the date
the radar gun was last calibrated those
are the questions you asked when you
fight tickets you say hey when uh how
far were you from my car where were you
parked so you parked there for a long
time you're insane no this is actually
every day I'm telling you I would hear
this stuff on the phone and she got out
of every single ticket and I hear her
saying things like my car's coated in
aluminum
so no radar beam can and it was just
amazing and she always got out of it
it's just not worth it I got out of a
red light camera ticket they had a video
of me going through the red and I still
beat how did you get out of it because I
I fought it and then it got uh denied
then I fought it again then it got
denied then I went to court and they
lost the video why aren't you why aren't
you putting this amount of energy into
my goddamn glasses
seriously David you do an amazing job
but I think if Sona was on this those
glasses would be here in 40 seconds yeah
I I could because she would go total
Crazy Ape on them in a way that
listen I don't wish this on you David I
don't want you to become a monster but
Sona is a monster and she would you
complimenting me I don't understand
what's happening I think you're an
incredible I think when King Kong got to
the top of the Empire State Building and
swatted those biplanes down it was
amazing you are in out of control insane
person you're the Kraken but guess what
you're you're an amazing Kraken you're
the Loch Ness Monster on crack and you
get it done every time what is this I
don't know if I should say thank you
just say thank you I don't want to say I
don't know I don't feel uh I don't feel
complimented you will once the drink
wears off yeah